not filming Instagram
I'm gonna get it out but you're not
gonna like how I'm gonna do it no Chloe
Chrisley is not here for big sister
Savannah documenting her morning Chloe
she is so amazing she's the boss she
truly is she is the boss yeah the 10
year old had some strong feelings
following the death of her pet fish
especially as her older siblings
Savannah and Chase were deciding how to
get rid of it oh Chase do not just get a
spatula with a squat in it
it's fine just get something with a slot
in it oh we're not wasting a spatula yes
we've got one floater stop I don't
care you're about to be getting your
dreams the final decision flush it down
the toilet which was not to Chloe's
liking
hey guys
all right rest in peace that's it that's
the words
but by morning Chloe seemed to be in a
happier mood reminding Savannah on the
drive to school you're not a morning
person but I'm a morning person yeah
I am not a morning person
but for Savannah Chloe giving her a hard
time is nothing new all right so we're
shopping I don't prove the top okay why
not the top and you need to wear a bra
with it what
roasted
sister
I'll tell you how it is
I don't like that I was like gosh
and they've even had some dance parties
schools canceled tomorrow
Crystal
Savannah giving a glimpse of lighter
times as she cares for both Chloe and
her 16 year old brother Grayson while
their parents Todd and Julie are behind
bars serving a combined 19-year prison
sentence for their bank fraud and tax
evasion convictions we need to figure
out healthier ways to cope with things
and deal with things and even if it's
just little things that I'm trying to
implement because I'm not their mom I'm
not their dad I'm I'm their sister and
since Mom and Dad surrendered in January
things at home haven't exactly been easy
the other night I just had a full on
breakdown I was trying to find Chloe
proper clothes to go and visit my
parents and find her hair stuff and I
just sat down on the floor and just
started crying you know Chloe's 10 years
old and I know that she's on TV at
certain times but outside of that I
think it's probably that Chloe's best to
Chloe be allowed to grow up as any other
10 year old would
but despite their challenges Savannah
said she recently got a sweet reminder
from her little sis the next day Chloe
and I were talking we were in the car
and she was like you're doing a pretty
good job
[Music]
foreign